on enquête sur des disparitions
certaines récentes d'autres qui remonte
à plusieurs années
oui
le mode opératoire est troublant j'étais
au groupe des disparitions avant hors
ecall on étudiait des enquêtes l'école
de police sont déjà bonnes pour les
archives
ouais tu fais partie des légendes je
peux pas continuer à couvrir
tu apportes réputation dis moi j'ai
croqué quand il se met à neiger c'est le
déclic pour la thur alors pour qui il
laisse le bonhomme de neige faire des
bonhommes de neige découper des tôles en
petits morceaux
c'est ce que font les enfants pour cris
de l'ordre on vient d'avoir un appel une
autre femme a disparu
a reçu un avis de recherche qui a
disparu sylvia en personne ces mois-ci
bio personnes pourquoi quelqu'un
signalerait votre disparition
il a signalé sa disparition
ensuite il a tué par le monde tout ça ne
doit filtrer
[Musique]
c'est un suicide point final vous êtes
sûr qu'il était seul
ou et catherine j'ai reçu ça c'est entre
lui et moi ils nous observent depuis des
heures ils nous baladent
vous pouvez sauver vous gêner je vous ai
donné toutes les plaies